[Musique]
je soupçonne un acte criminel et plus
n'exclut aucun suspect
[Musique]
je suis le lieutenant elliott et voici
le sergent wagner nous avons quelques
questions à vous poser
si je comprends bien le soir de sa mort
la famille s'était réunie pour fêter les
85 ans de votre père comment c'était là
la fête avant la mort de mon père
c'était super mesdames et messieurs je
vous demande de rester ici tant que l'
enquête n'est pas terminée
quoi on peut savoir pourquoi il ya du
nouveau
non non il n'y a rien de nouveau non on
ne peut rien savoir vous pensez que
c'est un membre de sa famille c'est ce
que vous sous-entendez
à
c'est le
vous adorez tous remuer le couteau dans
la plaie dans ton cul voilà ça c'est
cool a plutôt été dans le coup
je t'emmerde aussi des bons mecs de la
paire est clairement je t'emmerde
si vous avez quelque chose dites le
je soupçonne un acte criminel
et pour l'instant je n'exclus aucun
suspect
/
c'est un sac de noeuds et nous n'avons
pas encore fini de démêler tout cette
affaire pour le moment qu avons nous là
les experts kfc